we're going to take a look at how point
of view and Composition are very clearly
connected but before we show the
connections we have to sort of define
visually define what i mean by point of
view for example so take a look at these
four images now it doesn't look at it
but these images are of the identical
sample just simply taken with four
different points of view there it's true
that I also change the background on
them but generally what I did was I
moved the sample around or the camera
and we get four really completely
different-looking visual ideas of what
this stuff was about which one is right
I'm not sure there is a right in any of
this that's one of the fun things about
this kind of work there are no hard fast
rules that we have to follow but I
wanted to give this example to show you
that just by simply changing the angle
of your camera or moving your material
around you see different things again
we're learning to see in this course so
in this situation I wanted to show the
fabrication of this particular pyramid
sort of telling a story in a particular
image for now just take a real good look
at this pyramid that was made with this
wafer that was imprinted with a pattern
and I felt that this was not quite right
because there was a little ambiguity and
where the pyramids point is it's a
little too close to the curve of the
wafer so by simply raising the camera
ever so slightly we get it nice and
clean line without well let's continue
calling it ambiguity for the time being
here is an example where for this
particular device of micro rotor I shot
it from above because I was using a
stereomicroscope I had
this brand new piece of equipment that I
had to use of course because it's brand
new and from that point of view very
unfortunately you see all kinds of dust
and yuck which I could not get rid of
because I don't have control over the
light so I simply changed back to my
camera and my one of five lens with a
different point of view which gave me a
much cleaner image many times we get
stuck on a particular approach to
looking at things let's say directly
from above and it doesn't necessarily
give the best image here's an example
where this is a pdms that's been etched
with a grading on it and I took it with
this particular view and just by simply
changing the pdms to a slightly
different position we get a different
point of view let's go back and forth on
this and see it's kind of fun to do this
anyway but you'll notice that you really
this one has a better approach to
looking at the refraction but at the
same time you notice when we I did that
the shadow is changing in its position
again this is encouraging you to
understand that when you change your
point of view of course you're also
changing your composition in this
situation I had a petri dish with
various gels that had different colors
let's just leave it at that for the time
being this was my primary initial point
of view and I thought it was kind of
boring and so the point of view was a
little tighter in that I chose to get
the camera closer and I also included
different kinds of gels in this
situation larger ones it is a different
point of view in terms of your selection
of what it is that you are going to be
showing so these are not very deep
changes but enough to make very very
different images as for example this one
which is a glass wafer that's been
etched so that they're creating channels
on the wafer from this point of view and
here is another point of view where I'm
not showing the whole
thing and maybe we don't have to show
the whole thing all the time maybe we
can show the work by something that is
in my opinion a more interesting
composition and a different point of
view here a small change take a look at
both of these and I hope you see that in
the first one it was a bit of a sloppy
point of view in the sense that i'm
showing labels that really is not
something of value and so by simply
moving the camera slightly then focusing
a little closer it's a cleaner point of
view again this is also about God
position but they are very much
connected here is this researchers point
of view where he decided to show the
flexibility of this material and include
hands which is a good idea when you want
to show scale for me I decided to be a
little more playful and just playing
more around the flexibility in showing
the shadows of it and we did get a cover
of a journal which was nice whole
different point of view same material
both are good you know there's not again
it not one is better than the other
necessarily i decided to dig out from
the depths of my slide collection when i
was an architectural photographer to
show you a difference that does somewhat
inform us in this course here's a
beautiful space in california designed
by the simone Iguchi this is the first
image that I made and here is the second
image that I made let's go back and
forth a little on this as well and you
see in this second image I decided to
have the camera points slightly upward
of changing the point of view so that we
see a slant of sky I think this is a
better image I think it's more
interesting but I also think that it
allows the viewer to sort of parties
paid more in the image that is to kind
of go along upward and be part of paying
attention to what is going on with the
sky I think showing the edges and the
connection between the edge and
something beyond is an interesting view
of how to show things as I did hear back
to our world when I needed to show
bubbles for a book that we did I decided
to keep the edge of the plate showing
and show the background it is a point of
view that I felt sort of worked in here
is another point of view with the same
material which is better I the
interested to hear your opinions here is
a device with the researchers point of
view of it and this is my point of view
where I first of all like to get it in
focus but since we're talking about
point of view I'll stay with that and
all I did was I put it on a white
background and I just slanted the device
and the camera of this point of view and
I think it's a much more successful
picture and finally in this situation
when you do have a device that is almost
pretty much symmetrical if you're going
to take a photograph from above you just
better make sure that you make the image
symmetrical as well take a look at this
first one again and you know there's
nothing worse than an almost okay image
if it were really really off symmetry
that would work better than just a tad
off symmetry so my suggestion is to if
you do decide to make a symmetrical like
image just make sure it is a symmetrical
point of view